-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning
writer, actor, and director who
you know from his work on
"Saturday Night Live,"
"Documentary Now!",
and HBO's "Barry."
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend Bill Hader.
Hi, buddy.
-Hey, buddy. How's it going?
-Good. You know,
I think of you every day.
Viewers of our show will know
I have, of course,
my little Stefon nesting doll.
Did you know you've been joined
by Andy Samberg
as a mummy whose doink fell off?
[ Both laugh ]
-My doink fell off?
-Yeah, Samberg played a mummy
whose doink fell off,
and at the end of it --
at the end of it,
I told him, "That went great,"
and he said, "Oh, do I get to be
on the desk then?"
-He's always gunning
for my spot, man.
-Yeah, he wants your spot.
I think that you probably get
asked this all the time --
I know I do -- how do you think
Stefon would be doing
during a pandemic?
It strikes me that a lot of
what he does
would probably be
shut down right now.
-I don't know
if he would notice.
[ Laughter ]
I think he would kind of go for
a while and not really notice
and then --
-That's true.
And I guess this -- He does --
This is like
a natural mask, right?
-Yeah, it was a mask, yeah.
It was kind of a mask.
And he would -- I think he was
probably, you know,
patient zero on some level.
And he's probably had it a
couple times, and now he's fine.
-Yeah. I mean,
it does seem like --
Yeah, he probably went to
a club at some point
that was called Wet Market.
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah.
-I do feel like a lot of
the clubs that he went to
in New York City might not be
following, like,
de Blasio's rules.
Like, it feels like they were
already pretty underground.
-They were all
pretty underground,
if they, in fact, exist,
you know?
-Right. Are you saying,
this whole time,
Stefon might have been
projecting a version of himself
that wasn't entirely true?
-That's a thing I always laughed
about, because, you know,
when I would laugh doing that,
so much of it was just how bad
at his job he is,
you know, that he's lying.
And I always felt that
you were very --
You knew he was lying,
but you were being
very patient with him.
-Well, I remember Neal Brennan,
our friend Neal Brennan,
pointing out that he liked to
think of the producer backstage
with Stefon right before he went
on "Weekend Update"
being like, "Okay,
and just a reminder, Stefon.
We really want
St. Patrick's Day tips,
if you could just keep it
themed to that,"
and Stefon just, like,
promising this would be the time
that he would actually --
-Not listening to him at all.
He thinks -- He's like,
"The giant frog with the
headphone backstage told me.
-Did you -- I know you had
to put a pause on
Season 3 of "Barry,"
which I'm heartbroken by
because I'm
so excited to see it.
Where are you in production now?
-We were in -- Like right when
the lockdown happened in March,
we were a week away
from shooting.
So the last time I was in
a room with a lot of people
was the table read for
episodes 1 and 2 of Season 3,
and we were ready to go.
And then it all got shut down.
So, we actually wrote --
Season 3 is completely written,
ready to go.
And then, during this time,
we actually went
and wrote Season 4.
So we have both of those
kind of done.
So we're just waiting until we
can start shooting again.
-That's really exciting.
I imagine -- I mean, there was
such a wonderful cliffhanger
at the end of Season 2, but did
you worry that you had,
to some degree,
written yourself into a corner
that you had to find
a way out of?
-That's kind of what we do at
the end of every season.
You know,
at the end of Season 1,
we had written ourselves
this kind of cliffhanger,
and then -- Yeah,
and then you do it again.
And then, you know,
Alec Berg and I,
who I created the show with --
We were just talking about
this last night,
where it's a bit like having
a reoccurring character
on "Saturday Night Live,"
like we were just
talking about Stefon.
You kind of do
the first time you go out --
it's like the first season,
where you're like,
"Oh, that was fun.
It seems like they liked it,"
you know?
And then, the second time,
you have a little pressure.
You get recognition.
And then, by third time
you're doing it, you're --
The more I did Stefon or
the more we did Californians
or whatever, you always --
You know, it got just more
tense, you know?
More pressure on you to, like,
do new moves or whatever.
And on "Barry,"
I can't just rely on
John Mulaney to make me laugh.
So -- my lines, you know?
So, yeah, you know, it was --
It is very, very hard.
And, yeah, we ended on a
cliffhanger in the last year.
And, yeah, first day back in
the writers' room,
it was like, you know, everyone
going, "So, what happens?"
And we were like,
"I have no idea.
Really, really screwed
ourselves here."
And we're still saying it.
Like, yeah, we're still trying
to figure it out.
-I can't wait.
Obviously, I'm very eager
for you guys
to get back to work on that.
And I have more to
talk to you about.
We'll be right back
with more Bill Hader.